[Musique]
dans la nature sous nos latitudes
européennes l'arbre suit le rythme vital
et mélodique des quatre saisons
il s'éveille au printemps s'épanouit en
été
s'épuise en automne s'endort en hiver
pour s'éveiller à nouveau au printemps
ce cycle temporel fait d'une succession
infinie de morts et Renaissance est un
gage d'immortalité
gage d'immortalité qui a pu
s'interpréter jadis comme une allégorie
métaphysique de la mort et de la
résurrection de Dieu
c'est aussi cet arbre porteur du monde
que l'on rencontre sur une plaque du
célèbre chaudron de gain destrues
l'arbre est ici présenté à l'horizontal
ces trois racines sont orientées à
gauche vers la cuve aux géants
la cime à droite vers les 3/4 X
l'homme à cheval en haut galope donc
vers la cime de l'arbre tandis que
l'homme à pied en bas en redescend vers
la base
l'ensemble forme un manège tel un cycle
tournant de réincarnation
selon cette métaphysique la vie de
l'homme gravite autour de Dieu arbre
éternel principe et finalité de tout
un texte de l'antiquité témoigne
d’ailleurs que chez les Celtes l'arbre
était précisément considéré comme le
dieu souverain
au deuxième siècle de notre ère l'auteur
grec Maxime de tir rapporte en effet un
élément capital sur notre culture
occidentale
Zeus c'est-à-dire le dieu souverain
avait en Gaule la forme d'un arbre
les Celtes vénères Zeus et le Zeus se
celtique est un grand chêne
l'arbre en l'occurrence ici le chêne et
donc une figuration de Dieu
l'arbre Dieu celtique est manifeste sur
le gobelet de Lyon
d'origine druidique cet objet culturel
présente sur sa surface circulaire une
succession de personnages et d'animaux
mythologiques
on y voit notamment deux arbres
un arbre en souffrance autour duquel son
roulent un long serpent comme pour
l'étouffer
et un arbre en vigueur sur lequel pousse
une boule de gui qu'un druide pourrait
cueillir
le gobelet présente donc l'arbre divin
sous un double aspect une sorte de
passion et un don de soi
cette idée d'un arbre Dieu souverain
explique peut-être une statue comme
celle du musée Rollin à Autun trouver à
Anost en Morvan le personnage central et
dominant porte haut tous les autres sur
son dos sur ses bras comme le ferait les
branches d'un arbre
l'arbre divin qui porte le monde et
comme un à d'autres peuples tel le
freinent higgrasil chez les germes
la culture ancienne de la Gaule n'a pas
disparu avec la fin de l'Antiquité
tout en évoluant au fil des siècles elle
s'est conservée dans nos églises dites
romanes
ces églises abritent en leur sein une
matière païenne que chacun pourra
constater en les visitant lui-même
l'église de Vassy est située en
Haute-Marne
dans la nef un des piliers centraux
présente en saillie quatre colonnes
orienté aux quatre points cardinaux ces
colonnes ont en outre des dimensions
différentes
deux colonnes sont basses Nord et Est
deux colonnes sont hautes sud et ouest
et chaque colonne est coiffée d'un
chapiteau original historié en lien
étroit avec le monde végétal à l'Est un
jeune homme glabre agrippe avec vigueur
les deux branches d'un arbre branche qui
monte puissamment spirale feuillue et
donne des fruits sur les côtés
notre athlète a les bras et les jambes à
demi plier comme pour figurer un effort
intense ce dieu juvénile semble tirer
les branches vers le haut et l'extérieur
comme pour déployer la vivacité végétale
dans le monde
placé côté est donc soleil levant il
pourrait figurer le printemps
au sud une gueule féline dégorge des
terres un sauts de feuillage c'est le
seul des quatre personnages à être un
animal
le félin montre les dents et inspire la
force sauvage toute la végétation
jaillit en haut de la gueule même du
félin par sa dominance irradiante le
félin dégage une dynamique solaire
sur chaque côté du chapiteau se trouve
une autre gueule ce qui fait trois
gueules en tout
on note au passage que le relief est
renié sur le bord ce chapiteau est
clairement un emploi
il est probable que les quatre
chapiteaux correspondants sont plus
anciens que l'église sous sa forme
actuelle
placé au sud se fait l'un rayonnant de
végétation pourrai figurer l'été
à l'ouest un vieil homme présente un
visage triste avec barbe et cheveux
longs
les deux pointes longiligne de
samustache descend jusqu'au sol
de ses bras et cartés il a grippe
mollement des branches il semble avoir
la tête posée sur le tronc
notre homme paraît déjà plus ou moins
végétalisé
le contraste est saisissant entre le
jeune athlète glabre au bras replié vers
l'intérieur qui exprime la force et ce
vieux bonhomme à la moustache négligée
et au bras écartés qui expriment la
fatigue
sur ce vecteur équinoxial les deux
personnages figurent semble-t-il l'est
vigoureux et l'Ouest déclinant l'Ouest
est donc l'automne
enfin au nord un visage au regard
intense et grave projette ses yeux
sévères sous d'épaisses arcades
sourcilière
les deux pointes de ces moustaches
remontent le long des pommettes et
finissent en feuillage qui recouvre le
crâne
ses bras sont des feuillages tendus vers
les côtés sous son bras droit il y a un
fruit sous son bras gauche une feuille
fruits et feuilles proviennent d'un
arbuste fourchu les jambes de notre
héros végétal sont des torsades
enracinées le dieu est ici totalement
végétalisé
on note l'opposition solstitiale entre
le nord hiver qui recouvre visage et
verdure et le Sud était au visage
découvert qui diffuse la végétation le
Nord figure donc l'hiver
le dieu arbre prend ici la pose d'un
homme au braille écarté un peu à la
manière d'un crucifier la scène quasi
christique prouve la possible proximité
entre l'arbre celtique et le Dieu en
croix de l'Évangile
les emplacements des quatre chapiteaux
aux quatre points cardinaux indiquent
clairement le rôle saisonnier qui
incombe à chacun
en outre la dimension des colonnes n'est
pas fortuite les deux chapiteaux placés
en bas Nord et Est représentent l'hiver
et le printemps c'est-à-dire les saisons
montantes où le soleil va du jour le
plus court au jour le plus long de
l'année
à l'opposé les chapiteaux placés en haut
sud et ouest représentent l'été et
l'automne c'est-à-dire les saisons
descendantes où le soleil va du Jour le
plus long au jour le plus court de
l'année
les deux personnes âges au crâne
dégagées sont évidemment le printemps et
l'été quand le jour domine la nuit
tandis que les deux personnes âges au
crâne couvert sont l'automne et l'hiver
quand la nuit domine le jour
enfin détaille essentiel les quatre
saisons se suivent dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre c'est à dire
selon la course du soleil depuis
l'hémisphère nord
en résumé chaque personnage est situé
précisément là où il prend tout son sens
l'homme arbre au nord et en bas désigne
l'hiver
l'athlète à l'Est et en bas désigne le
printemps
le félin au sud en haut désigne l'été
enfin le vieux à l'ouest est en haut
désigne l'automne
il est difficile de croire qu'il puisse
s'agir d'un hasard
d'autant que l'on serait bien en peine
d'interpréter ces reliefs dans et
singuliers à l'aune de la Bible
il est possible que l'on ait plus tard
réorienter ces quatre dieux saisons en
leur substituant les quatre évangélistes
la représentation devient alors le
célèbre tetramorphe où le Christ trop
n’entourait de ces quatre biographes
Matthieu en homme marque en lion Luc en
Taureau et Jean en aigle
la culture ethnique de l'ancienne Gaule
s'est conservée dans maintes églises
celtiques souvent tapis dans les
profondeurs immaculées de nos régions
[Musique]
on a vu à Vassy le visage
identifié à l'hiver
avec en haut sa moustache dont les deux
pointes remontent sur les côtés du crâne
et en bas la végétalisation du
personnage avec des membres bras et
jambes transformés en branches
à Graville le même personnage apparaît
sur ce chapiteau l'humanité du visage se
reflète dans le regard et le nez en haut
les deux points de moustache remontent
au-dessus du crâne en bas à la place du
menton fleurit un lys dont les deux
racines remontent sur les côtés pour
aller former les deux spirales d'angle
ainsi à Vassy à Graville le personnage
présente de longs pointes de moustache
qui lui remontent au dessus du crâne et
en bas une végétalisation soit des
membres soit du menton
ce visage végétal de Gravil est situé
côté nord de la nef juste à la croisée
du transept il fait face à un autre
visage côté sud le visage Sud a un peu
les traits d'un félin il porte une barbe
stylisée et son front est dégagé de la
commissure d'élèves sortent deux tiges
qui s'en vont former les deux spirales
d'angle et ce visage surmonte une foule
de fleurs à six pétales cerclé d'un
hexagone fleur qui remplissent tout le
chapiteau
le rapprochement avec le visage sud de
Vassy est évident
dans les deux cas en effet on constate
un visage au crâne découvert d'allure
féline une bouche qui dégorge des tiges
ces tiges vont s'enrouler pour former
les spirales d'angle enfin sous le
visage c'est tout en flore fleur ou
feuillage
dans les églises anciennes les points
cardinaux semblent parfois jouer un rôle
indicateur qui confirme l'identité du
personnage figuré
au nord l'hiver est à la fois couvert et
couvreur de végétation
au sud l'été est à la fois découvert et
diffuseur de végétation
ce qui correspond au climat en hiver il
fait sombre et la végétation est
endormisson tandis qu'en été il fait
clair et la végétation est foisonnante
[Musique]
selon la configuration adoptée par
l'architecte de schémas peuvent
toutefois se présenter soit la séquence
est mise en scène sur un même pilier
comme avinci alors les chapiteaux Nord
et Sud se tournent le dos
soit la séquence est mise en scène sur
deux piliers comme à Graville alors les
chapiteaux Nord et Sud se font face la
place cardinale du chapiteau ne prend
tout son sens que par rapport aux autres
chapiteaux un peu comme les mots dans
une phrase
[Musique]
en résumé à Vinci l'hiver et l'été se
tournent le dos sur le même pilier
tandis qu'à Graville l'hiver et l'été se
font face sur des piliers contiguës
l'essentiel est que les personnages
soient situés de façon logique l'hiver
est en rapport avec le Nord l'été avec
le sud
dans ces sanctuaires Gaulois
l'hybridation entre l'homme et la plante
est parfois très explicite par exemple à
chanteuse le jeune héros pose à genoux
entre feuillage et pommes de pin mais si
l'on observe bien ses pieds et chevilles
ne sont pas humains il se poursuivent en
branche ce personnage n'est pas sur
l'arbre il est l'arbre c'est l'arbre
Dieu dans une phase saisonnière vu sa
jeunesse peut être est-il le printemps
ces scènes qui représentent le dieu
mi-homme mi végétal sont toutefois assez
rares
le plus souvent l'arbre divin est figuré
de façon plus réaliste l'arbre et
l'homme n'y sont pas fusionnels mais
dissociés par exemple l'homme se tient
aux branches de l'arbre
ainsi accunot plusieurs chapiteaux
montrent un homme qui tient des branches
d'arbres de ses bras écartés on note que
les jambes et pas seulement les bras
sont en position d'écartement
l'écartement des bras associés à
l'élément arboricole préfigure
iconographiquement le Christ en croix
mais il est difficile d'y voir en soi
une figuration du Christ
c'est plutôt un récit oral Gaulois qui
devait à l'époque en donner le sens
concret
à étampe le même personnage barbu tient
dans ses mains écartés des rinceaux de
feuillage
de façon plus stylisée à pond du château
le personnage est également placé les
membres écartés sur un décor végétal
le dieu homme se présente parfois
suspendu à l'arbre donc dans une
situation de quasi crucifixion
à Vézelay un chapiteau présente un
personnage qui par son martyr en
crucifixion rappelle le Christ en croix
mais les apparences sont trompeuses le
martyre est ligoté et non cloué sur un
arbre vivant et non sur une croix inerte
il est coiffé d'un lys et non d'une
couronne d'épines il n'a pas de blessure
au flanc et on lui tire les gens vers le
bas
l'oeuvre met sans doute en scène le the
celtique l'arbre due à la fois souverain
cosmique et homme martyr
à hautain la scène du carillonneur offre
des similitudes frappantes avec celles
de Vézelay
un homme tient ses bras en croix il
porte en travers des épaules une poutre
d'où pendent trois cloches de chaque
côté
on note que ces poignets sont ligotées à
la poutre et une cloche est suspendue à
sa taille
son visage est triste et résigné
deux hommes l'encadre celui de gauche
tient une cloche les deux bourreaux
agrippent des cloches de la poutre et
s'amusent à les tirer vers le bas
ainsi à Vézelay comme à Autun le héros
tient les bras en croix
il est ligoté à du bois arbre ou poutre
il est encadré par deux bourreaux les
deux bourreaux le tirent latéralement
vers le bas
sur un autre chapitre d'autain la scène
des deux cueilleurs présente
structurellement des ressemblances avec
les deux précédentes
un arbre trône au centre il déploie deux
branches latérales qui s'arrondissent en
volute vers les angles du chapiteau
deux hommes couronnés sont assis sur les
deux branches de l'arbre ils encuent
deux fruits
la cime de l'arbre est couronnée d'une
grosse pomme de pin encadrée de deux
feuilles ce qui donne à l'ensemble une
forme fleur de Lisée
ainsi le crucifial arbre le carillonneur
et l'arbre aux pommes de pin
correspondent aux mêmes personnes dans
une scène unique Dieu s'offre lui-même
aux hommes
à Saint-Denis ce chapiteau domine la nef
côté sud la tête humaine l'animal et
l'arbre fusionnent ici en un personnage
multiforme en bas le visage présente un
front Bossuet bestial avec des
excroissances sur les côtés du crâne qui
font à la tête humaine comme les cornes
naissantes d'un cervidé
le personnage Cornu diffuse un regard
intense et porte une barbe épaisse et
rayonnante de sa bouche il dégorge de
rinceaux qui remonte vers les angles
pour donner des grappes de raisin
sans nourrissent deux oiseaux perchés
sur les excroissances cornues
le dieu barbu tient à la fois de l'homme
par son visage du végétal par sa
diffusion buccale de rinceau fruité et
du cervidé par ses boissons
face à lui côté nord domine ce visage
vaguement humain qui porte de longues
cornes
son front est surmonté d'une fleur à 4
pétales
les longues cornes chemine sur les bords
où elle façonne des spirales aux angles
puis elle descendent en rinceau qui se
rejoignent en bas pour composer un beau
lit intérieur
on note que kornes et rinceaux sont
clairement en continuité preuve de la
connexion là encore entre monde végétal
animal et humain
les deux figures sont en fait
complémentaires le visage Nord a de
longues cornes et une fleur au-dessus du
front mais le grand lit sans bas est
recouvert le visage Sud a de courtes
cornes mais une barbe abondante d'où
jaillisse des rinceaux de fruits qui
nourrissent en haut les oiseaux
le jeu de corne ramène la scène mythique
audiogolois Ker nunos et l'on devine la
naturelle complémentarité entre les bois
du cerf et les bois de l'arbre
la ramure du cerf domine la forêt en
automne et au début de l'hiver quand
l'arbre est affaibli il verse symbolisé
par le nord tandis que la Ramée de
l'arbre domine la forêt au printemps et
en été quand le cerf est affaibli était
symbolisé par le sud
la ramure du cerf et la Ramée de l'arbre
sont donc en alternance d'où
l'alternance entre les deux divinités
l'arbre et kerulos
à moins qu'il ne s'agit sans fait du
même Dieu la même énergie qui se
manifeste tantôt en rameau d'arbre
tantôt en ramure de cerf
en tout cas les anciens Gaulois avaient
développé une métaphysique de la nature
Ramée rameur et barbe forment un langage
imagé du temps qui pousse et du temps
qui passe
toujours à Saint Menou un chapiteau
présente une gueule qui dégorge des
rinceaux de feuillage les tiges
latérales finissent en feuilles aux
angles tandis que les tiges du bas se
rejoignent pour former un magnifique
lisse
cette configuration est très fréquente à
Franchesse la gueule féline dégorge de
rinceaux qui se dédoublent les tiges du
haut se terminent en spirale les tiges
du bas composent un lisse en forme de
cœur
au Montet même scène de la gueule au
rinceau avec cette fois une pomme de pin
à la place du Lys
à plein pied la gueule féline dégorge de
rinceau symétriques sur les côtés et un
fruit vers le bas
dans la même église trône la gueule
féline tandis que des deux spirales
d'angle sort un fruit
on note la similitude frappante de cette
série de félins avec le félin de Vinci
que l'on associe à la belle saison de
l'été
que l'on songe que dans un sanctuaire
chrétien l'architecture d'origine aurait
dû refléter des scènes tirées de la
Bible mais dans les églises gauloises ou
romanes on trouve des scènes apparemment
tirées de la culture ethnique locale
la Gaule pays couvert de forêt de
prairies et de champfertiles et voué par
la Providence à glorifier l'univers
végétal
et les hommes qui habitent à penser le
monde à travers le logiciel de l'arbre
c'est pourquoi chez les anciens Celtes
on voit un culte aux chêne comme évoqué
plus haut par Maxime de tir
à l'époque druidique déjà ce dieu
suprême prenait plusieurs formes
soit un être souverain mi-homme qui
porte les autres dieux sur ses branches
soit un arbre en souffrance dénudé comme
en plein hiver et étouffé par un serpent
la composante arbre Dieu est très
fréquente dans nos églises anciennes
souvent le visage de Dieu trône au
milieu des feuillages
à Graville comme on a vu côté sud le
visage surmonte un champ de fleurs à six
pétales
tandis que côté nord il déploie ses
longues moustaches
surtout le puissant visage étant cadré
verticalement par Alice sous le menton
ce visage au lit ce sous le menton doit
avoir un sens précis car on le retrouve
ailleurs par exemple la caserberg
le personnage est ici glabre et chevelu
là le visage surmonte un végétal et trop
au milieu des feuillages
ou bien il est encadré de végétaux
même encadrement de feuillage à durcit
les vies
et à prélever
à artou placé en position dominante
parmi les feuillages le saint visage
trône barbu impassible et serein
au Puy-en-Velay deux têtes barbuses et
angoissées sont perchés en haut des
feuillages
à plein pied la tête glabre au menton
volontaire déploie une étonnante
chevelure en forme de feuillage
il y a un je ne sais quoi de
mérovingiens dans cette coiffe longue et
princière
détail intéressant ce visage hyper
chevelu se situe sur le même pilier à
l'opposé du félin à la langue pendue et
aux spirale fruité
[Musique]
donc c'est la même configuration qu'à
Vinci ou le visage enfouit sous ses
pointes de moustache est à l'opposé du
félin qui dégorge des rinceaux de
feuillage
la même colonne oppose le personnage
frileux sous sa chevelure ou sous sa
moustache et le félin solaire qui trône
dans l'abondance
sur ce chapiteau de Châteaumeillant une
série de têtes surmonte une rangée de
feuilles la tête centrale porte une
coiffe tout en hauteur composée de
feuilles
le personnage est encadré de deux têtes
à la chevelure léonine et montrant la
langue
à l'extérieur il y a des têtes plus
petites
on dirait le même personnage à
différentes étapes de sa croissance
végétale
sur cette autre relief on reconnaît le
même Dieu aux cheveux de feuillage
le personnage est mi-homme mi végétal
dans la même veine on trouve à ce lieu
une étonnante série de têtes perchées
sur des tiges épaisses et feuillus
compose un arbre à tête dont les têtes
seraient les fleurs et les fruits à
différents stades de leur croissance
on note au dessus des têtes principales
les deux spirales qui leur font comme
des cornes ou plutôt ici des feuilles
ce duo de feuilles sur un fruit être
ressemblant un peu au gui sur lequel on
reviendra plus loin
les têtes ont une allure humaine ou
animale et l'une présente ouvertement sa
langue au public
par son thème et sa présentation cette
série de têtes arboricole rappelle
beaucoup la statuette d'anoste en Morvan
avec sa série de têtes juchées sur le
personnage principal
le plus troublant c'est que les deux
séries bourguignonnes distantes de
seulement 20 km aurait presque 1000 ans
d'écart
une telle similitude suggère plutôt une
certaine proximité temporelle
à Saint restitue enfoui au fond de la
végétation apparaît comme à la dérobée
le visage barbu du dieu arbre
à l'origine les chapiteaux étaient
souvent peints ceux qui ont rehaussé la
brillance et l'expression comme à
Issoire ici la tête sacrée du jeune
homme surmonte les feuillages
là elle est enfouie dans les feuillages
l'alignement de tête se retrouve à bles
et à l'heure
à chanteuse le visage barbu trône sur la
face il présente sa langue au public
peut être pour exprimer sa
toute-puissance créatrice
à Ennezat le visage glabre jaillit au
milieu de rangée de feuillage
à saignent les feuillages sont stylisés
plus encore à Guérande
à Mela le visage domine au milieu de
chevrons de feuillage
là le héros en capuchonné se dresse bien
droit au milieu des feuilles stylisées
sur lesquels il pose ses mains
un neuvie saint sépulcre placé en angle
le personnage en buste et levé dans un
encadrement de volutes qui lui fait
comme une mandorle il porte un collier
tout autour il y a des feuillages
un marteau le personnage se présente
tantôt jeune et glabre tantôt vieux et
barbus
à Saint-Germain-des-Prés un jeune homme
glabbe surgit des feuillages les mains
levées telles un prêtre disant dominos
vos biscuits le Seigneur soit avec vous
en architecture il est d'usage de donner
le nom d'Ordre à certains types de
colonnes souvent inspiré de noms grecs
les plus connus sont l'ordre de Rick
l'ordre ionique et l'ordre corinthien
la colonne est conçue selon des
proportions mathématiques et son
chapiteau sommital contient des éléments
géométriques ou des feuillages
l'ordre ionique se reconnaît notamment à
ses deux belles volutes ou spirales
latérales 6 aux angles hauts du
chapiteau
c'est cet ordre que l'on rencontre dans
les églises celtiques ou romanes avec
souvent un ajout de taille les deux
spirales encadrent le visage de Dieu
cette figuration trinitaire visage
central encadré de spirale est trop
évidente et trop fréquente pour ne pas
avoir un lien avec la doctrine d'un Dieu
en trois personnes
les deux spirales d'angle forment
semble-t-il les branches latérales
stylisées du dieu arbre celtique on se
souvient à Graville du visage moustachu
encadré de deux spirales d'angle loin
d'être de simples éléments de décor les
spirales jouent un rôle actif
sur la face les deux tiges se rejoignent
en bas pour former le lys
sur le côté la spirale porte une feuille
épaisse
quant à la tige de la spirale d'angle
elle se prolonge jusqu’à la bouche du
visage moustachu de profil d'où elle
semble jaillir
c'est valable pour les deux côtés du
chapiteau
trois visages
identiques sont donc reliés entre eux
par un jeu de spirale feuillus
ce triple visage présente évidemment une
certaine tricéphalie
au musée de Langres on peut admirer le
célèbre Dieu à trois têtes de l'antique
Gaulle qui arborent ici une belle barbe
les excroissances crâniennes sont des
andouillés de cervidés la ramure indique
qu'il s'agit du Dieu car nous nos
le dieu a trois têtes de Graville se
rapprochent évidemment plus du cardinose
de Langres que du texte de l'Évangile
le visage divin de Graville et
moustachus il est encadré de deux
spirales d'angles et il surmonte un lys
cette configuration précise se retrouve
à Caen
le dieu chevelu et moustachu agrippe de
ses mains les deux tiges qui montent en
spirale d'angle et sous son visage un
lisse fleuri au milieu d'une rangée de
feuillage stylisés
la prise en main des tiges spiralées se
rencontrent à Fouesnant la scène donne
l'impression d'un prêtre tenant de cross
à ta mère ville le visage divin au
pointe de moustache en volute et à la
barbe bifide est encadré par deux cross
au musée de sens décroche richement
décorés présentent des scènes
religieuses étonnantes
ici un ange vient à la rencontre d'une
femme ce qui pourrait figurer
l'Annonciation
là en revanche la spirale de la crosse
finit en serpent et le serpent s'enroule
autour d'un bélier
l'association serpent bélier nous emmène
chez les Celtes païens
le serpent à tête de bélier est en effet
un célèbre personnage de la mythologie
celtique sur le chaudron de gain des
strup on le voit aux côtés notamment du
dieu Taranis
sur cette stèle du musée de Dijon le
serpent à tête de bélier se tient
verticalement aux côtés de sa femme
il est frappant de constater que
certaines crosses semblent tout autant
avoir été tenu en main par des druides
que par des évêques
à Quimper les deux spirales d'angle
semblent jaillir des épaules du
personnage
plus solennel à quand le héros porte une
longue robe de cérémonie debout au
milieu des feuillages il est encadré par
deux grosses spirales
à Saint restitue la tête barbue belle et
massive trône entre les deux spirales
d'angle au-dessus de deux rangées de
feuillage
au Puy-en-Velay la tête est encadrée par
deux spirales dont les tiges se joignent
au niveau de la moustache rectiligne au
dessus de feuillage
à l'essai les longues tiges des deux
spirales viennent ici toucher au menton
le visage barbu
là le visage porte une barbe bifide les
deux points se prolongent en deux tiges
qui forment les deux spirales d'angle
les deux spirales d'angle sont l'un des
principaux motifs de l'arc celtique des
églises anciennes souvent placé chacune
à un angle elles encadrent le visage
situé sur la face du chapiteau par
exemple un visage humain a Gravil
un visage félin à plein pied
ou un félin de corps à l'abbaye de
Fleury de Saint-Benoît-sur-Loire
on se souvient de l'arbre tête à Saulieu
les têtes les plus volumineuses se
situent sous un duo de spirale que l'on
a rapproché de feuilles de gui ou de
corne
à l'avardin on reconnaît le même
personnage une tête volumineuse avec sa
coiffe à deux spirales
il est ici associé à des félins
à Saint-Benoît-sur-Loire la double
spirale d'angle est ajustée précisément
au-dessus d'un visage
l'homme à gauche tend les bras croisés
vers le personnage à spirale et
s'apprête peut-être accueillir ce fruit
tête
le feuillage en arrière-plan indique la
dimension végétale de la Seine et la
palme que le héros tient dans sa main
gauche témoigne de son imminent martyr
certaines de ces figures médiévales
offrent une possible réminiscence de la
cueillette du gui par les druides
mais à bien y regarder les deux spirales
donne aussi à la tête divine comme des
cornes de bélier
le bélier ou mouton est un animal
sacrificiel
et le Christ n'est autre que l'agneau de
Dieu
placé dans une mandorle ce saint
personnage lève ses bras et touche la
double spirale d'angle
preuve encore du caractère sacré des
spirales le Christ est ici encadré de
deux seins
et Pierre avec la clé du ciel
enfin que les volutes ou spirales soient
en rapport avec l'arbre se vérifie par
leur fronton ici elle se déploie en
feuilles
ce qui rappelle Gravil ou la volute
donne une feuille
et plein pied où elle donne un fruit
à Clermont le visage barbu trône sur la
face du chapiteau au milieu des
feuillages il est encadré de deux
petites spirales aux angles
à Mozac même configuration le visage de
Dieu barbu et serein règne sur des
feuillages des côtés de sa barbe
s'élancent deux tiges qui finissent en
spirale aux angles
enfin sur certaines œuvres on trouve
l'agneau pascal entre les spirales à
Saint-Germain-des-Prés au-dessus de
grands feuillage l'agneau pascal culmine
sur les tiges spiralées
à Deuil-la-Barre l'agneau pascal trône
dans un cercle surmonté d'une couronne
elle-même encadrée de volutes d'angle
si les spirales d'angle sont fréquentes
sur les chapiteaux ce n'est pas le cas
sur les tympans pour une raison évidente
il n'y a pas d'angle mais on y retrouve
l'arbre et l'agneau pascal comme un
girolles où l'on va faire étape
le chaudron de gain destrupes découvert
dans les tourbes du Danemark à la fin du
19e siècle contient plusieurs plaques en
métal gravées de récit mythologique
celtique
[Musique]
la plaque au géants présente l'arbre
sacré ici au centre de l'image en
position horizontale ces racines sont à
gauche vers la cuve son sommet à droite
vers les trois garnis
le géant saisit un homme et le trempe
dans sa cuve
en haut galope une série de quatre
cavaliers
chaque cavalier présente une singularité
juchée au sommet du casque
le premier à droite porte un casque avec
une effigie d'oiseau le deuxième porte
un casque avec une effigie de sanglier
le troisième un casque accorde de
taureau le quatrième un casque
apparemment au croissant de lune
on note que le premier et le troisième
porte une lance et la queue de leur
cheval est courte tandis que le deuxième
et le quatrième ne porte pas de lance et
la queue de leur cheval est longue
ainsi les quatre cavaliers galopent sur
l'arbre de la cuve vers la cime
devant les cavaliers en haut il y a un
serpent
sous le serpent face aux quatre
cavaliers se dresse trois carnicks dans
lesquels souffle trois sonneurs
[Musique]
devant les trois sonneurs se tient un
piéton particulier qui porte une lance à
son épaule et un casque au sanglier
c'est le seul des Bons Hommes d'en bas à
posséder un casque avec une effigie à la
cime
devant lui si fantassins indifférencier
chacun tient un bouclier et sa lance
posé au sol semble soutenir l'arbre à
l'horizontale
face à la série de fantassins un chien
saute en l'air
l'arbre possède trois racines à gauche
côté cuve et 14 tiges
entouré de petites stries l'arbre
irradique comme un halo d'énergie
sur la plaque il est la seule figure à
symboliser la force vitale pure
dans l'ensemble la scène présente une
ronde autour de l'arbre
les hommes du haut les cavaliers vont
vers la droite ou le sommet de l'arbre
les hommes du bas les piétons vont vers
la gauche ou les racines de l'arbre
les trois carnicks marquent le point
d'arrêt en haut avec effet tombant et
tournant vers le bas à l'opposé le chien
sauteur marque le point d'arrêt en bas
avec effet levant et tournant vers le
haut
la ronde autour de l'arbre comprend 12
hommes les quatre cavaliers qui montent
les 6 piétons identiques qui descendent
auxquelles s'ajoutent le trempé dans la
cuve qui vient d'en bas et le piéton
coiffé d'un casque qui vient d'en haut
les trois souffleurs de karniques se
sont à part en dehors de la ronde ils
font le pendant du chien à gauche
tandis que le serpent et les karniques
se semblent annoncer la mort des
cavaliers le géant accomplit une sorte
de réincarnation des piétons
on dirait que l'homme à cheval est une
âme incarnée qui accomplit sa destinée
terrestre tandis que le piéton est une
âme désincarnée en attente de
réincarnation
cette mystique serait conforme à la
doctrine des druides qui enseignent
l'immortalité de l'âme et la
réincarnation dans un nouveau corps
en effet selon le grec posidonio se
reprit par César
le premier point de leur enseignement
c'est que les âmes ne périssent pas mais
qu'après la mort elle passe d'un corps
dans un autre il pense que c'est là le
meilleur stimulant du courage parce
qu'on a plus peur de la mort
le petit village de girolles est situé
dans le Loiret
son église présente sous le porche un
magnifique tympan dont la structure
générale offre des similitudes
intéressantes avec la plaque au géants
de gain destrupes
j'utiliserai ici le négatif de l'image à
maintes reprises pour faire mieux
ressortir les contours du relief
l'arbre souverain se trouvant bas en
position horizontale la base du tronc
est à droite la cime à gauche
de la grosse gueule à droite jaillit le
tronc qui se divise aussi tôt en deux
branches montantes longiligne onduleuse
et feuillus
des oreilles du géant sortent aussi des
feuilles
au-dessus de la gueule un rinceau quasi
circulaire se compose de trois têtes
intermédiaires et de feuillages
on note que les trois têtes intégrées au
rinceau dégorge chacune par trois
orifices la bouche et les deux oreilles
à l'instar de la grosse gueule à la
racine de l'art
en haut l'homme est nimbé d'une croix
ses yeux calmes et ouverts regardent le
lointain il porte une fine moustache
à son bras gauche on voit un bracelet ou
un torque avec des motifs
il est vêtu d'une longue robe de
cérémonie épaisse et richement décorée
qui lui descend jusqu'aux pieds
et l'on voit les doigts de sa main qui
supporte l'agneau sous le ventre
ainsi l'homme tient de sa main gauche le
rinceau feuillu à la manière d'un lacet
tandis que de la main droite il soulève
la nuit
l'agneau domine la Seine il est lui
aussi nimbé et regarde vers nous
de sa patte droite pliée l'agneau
soutient la perche qui porte la croix
on note que les trois croix sur les
nains ou sur la perche sont de type
solaire c'est-à-dire avec des branches
équidistantes
la croix perchée se tient au centre de
trois personnages l'homme l'agneau et un
visage aérien à la bouche puissante
la bouche grande ouverte éruque avec
force deux souffle latéraux et déroule
une interminable langue vers le bas
jusqu'à effleurer l'arbre
enfin au sommet de l'arbre vol un dragon
dont on reconnaît le visage les pattes
avant les ailes et la queue de serpent
le dragon avale ou dégorge les deux
branches hautes de l'arbre
ainsi la gueule du dragon en haut fait
le pendant de la gueule à l'envers en
bas les deux gueules encadrent le
puissant végétal
sur l'arbre juste au-dessous du buste de
l'agneau se dresse une feuille composée
de 9 folioles
sa dimension et son emplacement la
mettent particulièrement en valeur
elle ressemble étonnamment à une
coquille Saint-Jacques symbole de nos
jours du pèlerinage de Compostelle
cette singulière feuille coquille se
rencontrent dans d'autres églises comme
à Saint-Martin de Boscherville
et à Falaise
les similitudes entre girolles et gains
destruves seront plus faciles à lire si
l'on place les deux images l'une
au-dessus de l'autre et si l'on retourne
l'image du Chaudron
ainsi les deux arbres figurent dans le
même sens
dans les deux cas l'arbre est placé à
l'horizontal
à la base de l'arbre on trouve toujours
les abysses sous la forme d'un gouffre
humide
un gain destruque c'est la cuve aux
géants à girolles c'est la gueule à
l'envers
la cime de l'arbre contient une
composante complexes l'arbre finit entre
oiseaux serpent et bouche véhémente
le cavalier au sommet porte un oiseau
sur son casque face à lui il y a un
serpent et trois carnix
[Musique]
à girolle au sommet de l'arbre vole un
dragon il a des ailes d'oiseaux et une
queue de serpent
et à côté le visage à la bouche
puissante déroule sa gigantesque langue
ainsi le dragon associe les éléments
oiseaux et serpents et le visage qui
éruque fait écho aux trois carnix
le géant ou le dieu maîtrise la scène
mais toujours en arrière-plan soit en
arrière des hommes soit en arrière de
l'agneau
le maître de cérémonie porte
manuellement une créature soit l'homme
qu'il trempe dans sa cuve soit l'agneau
enfin le quadrupède cheval ou agneau
très démonstratif est aligné dans le
sens montant de l'arbre
en résumé l'arbre divin est lié à un
dieu figuré en géant qui est le maître
d'oeuvre d'un rituel au cœur de la terre
il y a cette idée de cycle de retour
perpétuel comme dans un manège que l'on
serait tenté d'identifier avec la
doctrine druidique de la réincarnation
again destrup l'effet tournant est
évident le géant transforme les piétons
du bas qui viennent à lui en cavaliers
du haut qui s'en éloigne les hommes
tournent autour de l'arbre comme sur un
manège et c'est manuellement que le
géant assure le cycle
agirolles l'effet tournant se trouve
peut-être dans l'arbre lui-même avec ce
jeu d'alternance entre la gueule à
l'envers d'où sort le tronc et la gueule
du dragon d'où sortent les deux branches
l'effet tournant est rendu surtout par
ce curieux rinceau que brandit le dieu
rinceau composé de têtes et de
feuillages à la fois vivant et macabre
cela s'est forme une figure fermée comme
un cycle tenu dans la main du Dieu
ainsi dans les deux cas le dieu maître
du cycle est lié à l'arbre divin et il
assure de ses propres mains le cycle
répétitif de la vie de la mort et de la
Renaissance
les deux reliefs présentent donc une
structure similaire mais à quoi
correspond cet arbre le tympan de
l'église apporte peut-être un indice
juste en dessous de la tête de l'agneau
s'ouvre une large feuille à 9 folioles
et à la suite descend la langue
puissante du visage aérien
or dans le calendrier liturgique
chrétien l'agneau qui porte la croix
indique pas donc la mort et la
résurrection du Christ situé à la pleine
lune d'équinoxe de printemps et un mois
et demi plus tard Pâques est suivi de la
Pentecôte la descente sur les apôtres du
Saint-Esprit appelé aussi langue de feu
ainsi la progression de l'arbre indique
celle de l'année liturgique
le tympan des glisse pourrait donc
reseler la Sainte Trinité Dieu le Père
en homme le fils en agneau et le
Saint-Esprit envisage aérien à la langue
de feu
pourtant demeure tout le reste l'arbre
souverain la gueule à l'envers dou
jaillit l'arbre le dragon à la cime de
l'arbre où le lacet aux trois têtes
feuillus
tout cela ne serait guère trouvé
d'explication dans la Bible
comme souvent les églises celtiques
contiennent des thèmes tellement
archaïques que les reliefs historiens
paraissent précédés l'Évangile plus que
le suivant
[Musique]
l'arbre divin qui surgit de la gueule à
l'envers comme un girolle est un élément
fondamental qui se rencontre dans
maintes église
à plein pied l'arbre se déploie
verticalement
d'abord de branches latérales finissent
en volume et pomme de pin le tronc
poursuit sa lancée vers le haut et se
divise en deux branches qui se
rejoignent à la cime pour former une
belle feuille en cœur
à la base de l'arbre Gilles l'élément
insolite
une gueule animale renversée il s'agit
apparemment d'un félin
cette gueule féline qui dégorge du
végétal et quasi identique à celle de
Vinci sauf que la gueule féline y est
là-bas à l'endroit et en haut du
chapiteau
alors qu'à plein pied elle est à
l'envers et en bas du chapiteau
cette similitude inversée pourrait
indiquer des solstices opposés comme
l'été en position haute et l'hiver en
position basse
à ce lieu la gueule en bas est placée à
l'endroit et non à l'envers peut-être
pour des raisons esthétiques mais elle
dégorge malgré tout ces deux rinceaux
vers le haut
à chauria la gueule à l'envers dégorge
au centre de rinceau verticaux qui monte
s'enroule et se séparent pour finir en
épais feuillage enlacer
de la même gueule sur les côtés sortent
deux serpents zébrés qui ont dû vers les
flancs du chapiteau là il dégorge ou
dévore d'autres troncs d'arbres
c'est la même configuration complexe
qu'à girolles avec la gueule à l'envers
à la base de l'arbre et le dragon à la
cime
agirol et Astoria en effet l'arbre divin
jaillit de la gueule à l'envers
l'arbre se compose de deux branches
montantes et un reptile dragon ou
serpent zébré ouvre sa gueule à l'autre
extrémité de l'arbre
composante très proche du chaudron de
gain des scrup ou l'arbre divin est
encadré ou racine par la cuve et à la
cime par le serpent
à Sélestat la gueule à l'envers dégorge
une sorte de tronc auquel sont attachées
par une sangle de serpent pliés en rond
à Issoire la gueule à l'envers dégorge
un bel arbre à la forme plus ou moins
fleur de Lisée
on note les branches latérales qui
finissent en volute
l'arbre est ici encadré par deux
porteurs de moutons
la synthèse entre la cuve aux géants du
chaudron de gain destrupes et la gueule
à l'envers des églises se trouve
peut-être dans le baptistère
Achille un batistère présente une gueule
féline à l'envers dou jaillissent de
rinceaux qui s'enroulent et qui donne
des feuilles et des fruits
baptistère quasi identique à Nouvion le
vineux
à Saint-Denis sur un baptistère c'est
cette fois d'un récipient que sortent
les rinceaux de feuillage et de fruits
on a donc une correspondance sur le même
type d'objet le batistère entre la
gueule à l'envers et le récipient qui
tous deux des gorges de rinceau de vie
le baptistère nous ramène au chaudron de
gains
mystérieuse scène d'immersion qui évoque
plus une sorte de baptême qu'une noyade
ainsi la cuve au géant est peut-être le
baptistère du Dieu
Lucain est un auteur latin contemporain
des évangélistes dans son poème il
évoque trois dieux gaulois tout àtesse
Esus et Taranis
en marge de son texte des scoli ou
commentaires ont été ajoutés durant le
Haut Moyen-Âge ces ajouts ne sont pas
sans intérêt car à cette époque reculée
les traditions païennes étaient encore
vivaces
celui qui a écrit ce commentaire et
d'une telle précision qu'il aurait pu
avoir sous les yeux le chaudron devient
destrupes
selon le témoin le dieu totaltesse ou
Toutatice plonge un homme tête la
première dans un tonneau rempli de
liquide
mercure dans la langue des Gaulois est
nommé tout à tête lequel était honoré
chez eux de son humain de ta tête
mercure chez les Gaulois est apaisé
ainsi dans un tonneau plat un homme est
plongé par la tête pour y être noyé
sur le chaudron ce géant qui baptise par
immersion n'est donc autre que l'ancien
Dieu de ta Tesse
dès lors au vu de l'archaïsme de
certains baptisters sur lesquels ne
figure aucune référence biblique leur
origine interroge
s'agirait-il parfois de cuve druidique
sur main baptistère il y a des têtes
souvent six aux angles qui prennent
l'apparence de masques figé à censéverin
un baptistère porte à chaque angle le
visage du dieu barbu chevelu et serein
la Sainte Face est ici placée entre deux
lions affrontés retournés et de cils
à gerpin un baptistère circulaire
présente quatre têtes
et entre les têtes des motifs en
entrelac
à celles un baptistère octogonal
présente quatre visages en relief
un Dinant un baptistère présente quatre
têtes une à chaque angle
idem à OK
à Ferrières-en-Gâtinais
à Perros-Guirec
Ada oula cette vasque à tout d'un ancien
battistère le pourtour présente des
petites têtes plusieurs motifs
remplissent l'espace entre les têtes
la cuve des anciens druides comme
présenté sur le chaudron de guerre des
trucs serait donc devenu le baptistère
de l'église
qu'est-ce que le baptême c'est la mort
et la renaissance du baptisé dans le
Christ parfois le plus grand
retournement de toute une vie
comme disait l'évêque Rémi au roi des
Francs Clovis brûle ce que tu as adoré
adore ce que tu as brûlé
l'aNTIC rituel de passage des druides
semble donc avoir survécu dans le
baptême chrétien
si l'on résume l'arbre divin des anciens
Gaulois était plantés soit sur un bâti
terre comme en témoigne la cuve aux
géants soit sur un crâne la gueule à
l'envers
cette composante précise du crâne à la
base de l'arbre divin rappelle aussi un
célèbre épisode christique
selon l'Évangile la croix du Christ est
plantée sur la colline du Golgotha qui
signifie en hébreu le mont du crâne
la coutume veut que ce crâne du Golgotha
soit celui d'Adam le premier homme
ainsi dans les sanctuaires celtiques et
dans la Bible le bois sacré de Dieu
arbre ou croit se dresse sur une tête
que à l'envers ou crâne d'Adam la
correspondance est frappante la croix
divine plantée sur le crâne d'Adam fait
écho à l'arbre divin planté sur la
gueule à l'envers
pourtant il y a quelque chose
d'archaïque dans les sanctuaires de la
Gaule et de moderne dans l'Évangile
il est en effet difficile de suivre le
raisonnement qui nous ferait passer du
récit chrétien humaniste et urbain au
décor rural et mythologique des églises
gauloises
même si la remarque prend à l'envers la
chronologie que nous avons apprise à
l'école tout se passe comme si les
reliefs historiés de nos églises
médiévales dataient d'avant l'Évangile
une telle image sacrée dont la Bible
n'est pas la source ne serait-elle pas
antérieure à la christianisation
telle la croix qui porte le Christ
l'arbre divin porte souvent une feuille
ou un fruit sacré
à plein pied on se souvient de l'arbre
qui surgit de la gueule à l'envers il
entre la ses branches fertiles jusqu’à
donner à la cime une feuille en forme de
cœur
apon du château l'arbre au tronc doré et
aux feuillages verts portent au centre
une immense feuille rouge qui retombe en
son milieu et tout à la cime un petit
fruit rouge
un Beaugency l'arbre se présente sous
une ligne épurée
de son troncuissant se déploie deux
branches latérales en spirale et
symétrique tandis qu'à la cime surgit
une excroissance feuille ou fruit en
forme de cœur qui semble en être la
valeur ajoutée
l'arbre se situe sur la face du
chapiteau alors qu'aux angles trônes
soit une tête à la rotondité marquée
soit une spirale
tête arbre et spirale forment une sorte
de Trinité
mais elle ne saurait être tirée de la
Bible le logiciel d'origine est ailleurs
un lurcit les vies la configuration
stylisée est quasi identique à celle de
Beaugency
aux angles il y a une tête à la
rotondité marquée et au centre le
végétal
à Dijon un chapiteau présente l'arbre
souverain en haut dans un carré dominant
il déploie ses deux branches latérales
tombantes et portent à la cime un fruit
en forme de sphère
l'arbre est encadré par une spirale à
droite et des cercles concentriques à
gauche
à Neuilly en daim ce chapiteau montre en
bas une rangée d'arbres similaire à
celui de Dijon
à la cime des deux arbres de gauche il y
a une sphère cueillie ou amenée par deux
oiseaux aux cousins lacets
et entre les deux sphères une spirale
à droite sur le même chapiteau un arbre
a aussi une sphère à la cime cette fois
tenue par un lion saisit lui-même par un
oiseau
il s'agit là d'une structure précise que
l'on retrouve à Beaugency à Dijon et à
neuilly-en-bain l'arbre se présente avec
deux branches tombantes et symétriques
la valeur ajoutée sphère ou coeur se
situe au sommet et la spirale aux côtés
[Musique]
quand l'arbre divin est stylisé il se
rapproche de façon frappante du célèbre
littéraldique comme abré-le-véné
un néry-les-bains l'arbre jaillit des
feuillages et déploie ses branches
latérales en arrondi il porte une
excroissance au sommet
à Locmariaquer les branches latérales
spirales et symétriques encadrent le
fruit dominant en haut au centre
à Saint désirer l'arbre déploie en bas
des branches horizontales et en haut des
branches montantes à chaque angle du
chapiteau trône une tête
le personnage de droite lève les mains
comme s'il portait la voûte céleste à la
façon du Titan grec Atlas
on note la même configuration à Saint
désirer qu'à l'ursit les vies ou
Beaugency avec l'arbre sur la face du
chapiteau et les visages ou la spirale
aux angles
à shuria l'arbre présente une feuille
centrale et dominante ornée de trois
nervures la feuille étant cadrée de deux
branches qui finissent en volute à
chaque volute prend une pomme de pin
un novice insépulcre l'arbre déploie de
son tronc deux branches latérales ces
tiges aux feuilles tombantes se
rejoignent au sommet pour former un lys
renversé
à Perros-Guirec le lys est aussi
présenté à l'envers mais toujours avec
ses deux spirales latérales et sa pointe
ou son fruit à son sommet
un Deuil-la-Barre un chapiteau montre le
lystronant au-dessus d'une épaisse
rangée de feuilles stylisées les deux
branches en spirales du Lys se
poursuivent en tiges qui s'en vont
former les deux spirales d'angle
allez c'est l'arbre du 20 pouces en
hauteur et produit une pomme de pin à
son sommet l'arbre est encadré de deux
feuilles qui montent en spirale d'angle
sur ma relief l'arbre dit 20 ou le
lyséraldique est encadré par deux lions
un chef du pont le lys de forme très pur
et effilée est encadré par deux lions
qui semblent le vénérer
scène presque identique à vignorer le
végétal est encadré par deux lions dont
les pattes droites tiennent délicatement
la base
l'arbuste semble promise à grandir
l'arbre c'est ici épanouie en plusieurs
étages de branches qui finissent en
petite volute
étrangement l'arbre est entouré d'une
sorte de Mandor le qui lui fait comme un
cercle rayonnant en forme d'amande
dans l'art chrétien la Mandor est un
ovale qui entoure les personnages
sacrées tel le Christ ou les saints
à l'évidence l'arbre de vignoris est
divin cette divinité de l'arbre répond
parfaitement à la vision antique qu'on
avait les Gaulois
Zeus le dieu souverain à la forme d'un
arbre
à moi ça que la frise d'un chapiteau
offre ce lisse épanoui il se compose
d'une racine surmontée de deux volutes
latérales au-dessus s'élance un lisse
d'où jaillissent deux tiges fruitées le
divin végétal est encadré par deux lions
affrontés au visage tourné vers le
public
à Gourdon deux lions affrontés encadrent
une grande feuille en forme de coquille
Saint-Jacques
à Saint-Germain-des-Prés les feuilles
latérales telles des bras écartent le
menton redressé des deux félins ce qui
donne aux puissants végétales une forme
vaguement humaine
on sait que l'arbre et l'homme peut
fusionner l'arbre est alors une
silhouette humanisante comme un Vassy
à l'inverse est-ce que l'homme ne
pourrait pas avoir une silhouette
arborisante
à Châteaumeillant on a rencontré un
personnage auquel la coiffe
surdimensionné donne une allure de roi
chevelu mérovingiens
son imposante chevelure lui confère une
certaine végétalité qui le rapproche de
l'arbre divin et ce d'autant plus
qu'apparaît la même configuration
qu'avec l'arbre
l'homme déploie en effet une belle barbe
au pointe de moustaches en volume il
porte une chevelure épaisse et insolite
de gros feuillage qui lui fait comme une
mandorle de sainteté et il est encadré
de deux lions qu'il semble avoir
domestiqué
[Musique]
on reconnaît donc le même personnage
sous la forme soit d'un arbre souverain
à Vignery soit d'un homme arborisant à
Châteaumeillant
toujours notre héros est enrobé d'une
mandorle de feuillage et encadré de deux
lions de cils
l'arbre divin est parfois encadré par
d'autres créatures que des lions un
Mozac ce sont deux hommes genoux à terre
qui présentent au public les fruits
où l'arbre porte un seul fruit qui est à
la jointure des tiges du haut l'un des
deux hommes déploie une barbe
quand ce ne sont pas deux hommes ce sont
deux cent torts qui présentent les deux
pommes de pin au public
enfin l'arbre souverain intègre parfois
une scène complète
ici on voit à droite un guerrier barbu
qui triomphe d'un lion
et à gauche un homme glabre qui
chevauche un poisson
on voit surtout au centre l'arbre divin
avec ses deux branches celle de gauche
porte un fruit celle de droite une
feuille
cette configuration précise de l'arbre
avec fruits à gauche et feuilles à
droite est identique à Vinci
ce décor minutieux qui renvoie le même
écho d’église en Église n'a rien de
fortuit et révèle une remarquable
organisation sous-jacente cet arbre
divin est évidemment ni l'arbre d'Eden
ni celui de GC et ce n'est pas non plus
la Sainte Croix pourtant on le retrouve
partout
[Musique]
les cultes rendus jadis à la nature ou à
bon de les esprits de la forêt sont
regroupés sous le nom générique de
paganisme apparemment un milieu du
christianisme
on sait par l'archéologie que les
anciens Celtes vénérer le gui
sur le gobelet de Lyon daté du début de
notre ère une touffe de Guy pousse sur
la branche d'arbre qui surmonte le
sanglier
le gui est facilement reconnaissable à
ses feuilles à deux lobes allongés
il s'agit d'une plante parasite dont les
graines germes n'ont pas dans la terre
mais sur un arbre
la plante prend la forme générale d'une
grosse boule verte au feuillage
persistant toute l'année
le gifle rit en mars avril puis
doutanovembre apparaissent de petites
baies blanches remplies d'un liquide
visqueux et toxique
en Allemagne dans le Landes le tumulus
de globaire a révélé la statue d'un
homme daté du 5e siècle avant notre ère
au d'un mètre 86 le personnage figure
semble-t-il un dieu druide avec torque
bracelet et bouclier et une surprenante
coiffe en feuille de gui
cette coiffe a de l'Aube ressemble de
façon frappante à la coiffe à deux
spirale que l'on rencontre sur ma relief
d’église
à ce lieu on a vu des têtes coiffées de
deux spirales qui surgissent elles les
fruits d'un arbre
à Saint-Benoît-sur-Loire des personnages
ont la tête rehaussée de deux spirales
détails peut-être révélateur on note que
les deux excroissances sont parfois
asymétriques
c'est le cas globaire le personnage
présente clairement une feuille de Guy
plus grande à sa droite qu'à sa gauche
or à l'avardin même configuration la
tête présente sa spirale de droite avec
plus de courbes que celle de gauche
mais là c'est le contraire sa spirale de
gauche offre plus de courbes que celle
de droite
le pilier des Nautes à Paris présente un
personnage armé d'un outil qui agrippe
un arbre peut-être un druide qui va
cueillir le gui
un beau gencive le personnage équipé de
SERP figure peut-être plus un druide
qu'un évêque
on a vu avec Maxime de tir que les
Celtes représentaient leur dieu
souverain sous la forme d'un grand chêne
or c'est sur les branches de cet arbre
Dieu que poussait précisément ce que les
druides considéraient comme le remède à
tous les mots de la terre à savoir le
gui
Pline l'Ancien est un auteur latin du
premier siècle de notre ère dans un
célèbre passage de son histoire
naturelle il décrit avec minutie la
cérémonie de la cueillette du gui par un
druide
tout commence par le choix de l'arbre un
certain type de chaîne
il ne faut pas oublier l'admiration
quand nous les Gaulois les druides ainsi
appellent-ils leur nage n'ont rien de
plus sacré que le gui et l'arbre sur
lequel il pousse pourvu que ce soit ta
chaîne rouvre ce qui pousse sur lui
c'est un fait il croit que c'est envoyé
du ciel et que c'est le Dieu lui-même
qui part ce signe à élu l'arbre
puis après avoir trouvé le guide
accueillir on organise la cérémonie
selon le calendrier lunaire
comme il est très rare d'en trouver une
fois découvert c'est avec moult
vénération qu'on le colle le sixième
jour de la lune dans leur langue il
l'appelle le guérisseur universel
sacrifice et repas ayant été préparés
sous l'arbre selon l'usage ils avancent
deux taureaux de couleur blanche dont
les corps ne sont alors attachés pour la
première fois
enfin c'est la cueillette proprement dit
un prêtre paré d'un habit blanc monte à
l'arbre et avec une serpe d'or tranche
ou le gui que l'on reçoit dans un linge
blanc puis on y molle les victimes en
priant le dieu du bien vouloir faire don
de prospérité en boisson on pense qu'il
en fécond tout animal stérile et qu'il
est un remède contre tout poison
pour ceux qui nous intéresse le rituel
druidique peut se résumer ainsi
on se réunit à une certaine lune le gui
est accroché au chênes mais le chêne n'a
pas produit le gui les druides
décrochent le guide du chêne il le
dépose dans un linge blanc le gui est vu
comme envoyé du ciel le gui est censé
guérir tous les mots
comme on peut le constater la cueillette
du gui obéit un cérémonial dense et
précis
y a-t-il dans l'Évangile un événement
marquant dans lequel les druides
auraient pu reconnaître l'équivalence de
leur enseignement
on constate un parallèle surprenant
entre la cueillette du gui et la
déposition du Christ
en effet la mort et la résurrection du
Christ sont fêter un pack c'est à dire à
la pleine lune de printemps le Christ
est accroché à la croix mais la croix
n'a pas produit le Christ
les premiers chrétiens décrochent le
Christ de la croix
il le dépose dans un seul blanc
[Musique]
le Christ est envoyé du ciel
le Christ rachète tous les péchés des
hommes
il est clair que le guide des druide et
le Christ sont tous deux des divinités
du salut
le dénominateur commun peut s'énoncer
comme suit le Sauveur le gui le Christ
guérit les hommes de tout mal du péché
originel il est accroché à un arbre un
chêne la croix à une certaine lune
Pâques on l'en détache pour le déposer
dans un tissu blanc linge linceul
le Sauveur est envoyé directement du
ciel et sacré
à une date indéterminée des druides ont
dû avoir vent de l'Évangile ils ont pu
identifier le Christ en croix à leur
propre dieu sauveur qu'ils avaient
coutume d'Honoré sur un chêne sacré
la similitude de ces deux scènes
druidiques et cristique et d'autant plus
troublante que les deux textes sont de
la même époque Pline est un contemporain
des quatre évangélistes
l'origine de la liturgique chrétienne et
son lien possible avec le druidisme
n'est pas nouvelle
en 1609 dans son livre parthénie
l'avocat Sébastien rouliard analyse le
fait déjà connu que les druides
donneraient jadis à Chartres une vierge
enceinte d'un dieu
l'auteur évoque aussi la similitude
frappante entre cueillette du gui et
descente de croix
car c'est le même arbre sous lequel les
druilles de Gaulois prêtent de la Vierge
qui en forterait venait sacrifier leurs
deux taureaux non point au démon mais
audio du ciel le fils duquel il venait
recevoir et dépendre de la croix sous la
forme du gui lequel discline il réputé
pour envoyer du ciel et que c'était
signe que l'arbre auquel il s'attachait
était choisi de Dieu il le cueillait
avec une serpette d'or le plus pure des
métaux et le recevait dans un linge
blanc comme fuir ceux qui dépendait à
notre seigneur de La Croix peut-on sous
l'ombre du paganisme reconnaître de plus
haut mystère de notre religion
chrétienne
[Musique]
il y a donc continuité théologique de
l'arbre à la croix
la Sainte Croix porte le fruit
Rédempteur le Christ comme jadis le
chêne sacré portait le remède universel
le gui
la présence de l'arbre divin dans une
église celtique ou romane prend alors
tout son sens
à plein pied Dieu s'offre au monde à
travers l'image de l'arbre sacré-cœur
idem à Beaugency avec un graphisme plus
abstrait
quand ce n'est pas le fruit c'est
l'homme qui s'accroche à l'arbre divin à
Étampes le héros agrippe de rinceau
feuillus de forme circulaire
à culo notre divin héros saisit ici des
branches
là les membres écartés il est suspendu
au végétal ce qui associe l'incarnation
au don de soi
par transfert théologique c'est
probablement cet arbre divin des anciens
Celtes qui a poussé au culte chrétien de
la croix
car jamais lors de sa résurrection le
Christ n'a exhorté ses disciples à
adorer l'instrument de son supplice
c'est donc bien d'ailleurs que ce culte
de la sainte croix a été insufflé il se
trouve justement que le nom d'un dieu
gaulois semble pouvoir être rapproché du
nom de Jésus
dans le texte de Lucas déjà mentionné
plus haut une note apporte des
précisions sur le Dieu ezus
mars est apaisé ainsi un homme est
suspendu à un arbre jusqu'à ce que ses
membres vidaient de leur sens se
détachent
une stèle du pilier des notes à Paris
montre un homme outil en main à l'assaut
d'un arbre avec le titre hésus
mais on ignore qui était juste l'homme
l'arbre ou le gui que le druide
s'apprête peut-être à couper
toujours est-il qu'il existe chez les
Gaulois insulissent religieux où l'on
suspend un homme à un arbre et le dieu
concerné par ce supplice porte le nom
des US avec ou sans h
c'est là une ressemblance frappante avec
le Dieu de l'Évangile Jésus lors de son
supplice est suspendu à l'arbre de la
Sainte Croix
quant aux deux noms divins ils sont
d'une homophonie quasi parfaite entre le
dieu gaulois etus et Jésus si l'on
prononce sa lentille
si longtemps une synthèse entre les
cultes druidiques et chrétiens le dieu
sauveur est envoyé du ciel et sacré
concernant ce dieu un homme est suspendu
à un arbre
à une certaine lune on détache de cet
arbre ce Dieu Sauveur pour le déposer
dans un tissu blanc
il guérit les hommes de tous les mots le
nom de ce Dieu Sauveur et soit hésus
soit Jésus
l'arbre divin des anciens Celtes s'est
conservé non seulement sur les reliefs
d'église mais aussi dans la littérature
médiévale notamment dans la geste de
Charlemagne fils de Pépin le Bref
selon une légende tous les acteurs
principaux de la matière de France
descendent de trois lignes
le lignage royal qui bénéficie
exclusivement de l'intervention divine
c'est celui de l'ange du roi Charlemagne
et de Roland le lignage des rebelles à
savoir donc de maillence au Gilles
danois gannelon ou les quatre fils
aimons enfin le lignage de Garin à
savoir Girard de Vienne Olivier et Aude
la chanson de geste d'ohon de Mayence le
résume ainsi
il n'y a que trois gestes au royaume de
France la première est celle de pépins
et l'ange la suivante celle de Garin de
monglas de la France et la troisième
celle de dons de Mayence
pour en saisir toute la Genèse il faut
remonter au milieu du huitième siècle à
Pépin le Bref quand trois garçons vont
naître en même temps dans des
circonstances identiques
et cela tandis que Séville une tempête
miraculeuse
quand Charles naquit deux autres enfants
moi donc et Garin le soleil rougit
échangea d'apparence les vents luttaient
la terre tremblait là-haut la nu
devenait sombre la tempête souleva
a-t-elle grondement que tout devait en
était bouleversée
trois foudres tombent alors du ciel en
trois lieux différents
[Musique]
le premier éclair s'abat devant le
château de Paris au moment où l'épouse
de pépin Berthe aux grands pieds
accouche de leur fils et futur empereur
d'Occident Charlemagne
or voilà que la foudre en heurtant le
sol a creusé un cratère d'où se met à
croître un arbre
et cet arbre vivra aussi longtemps que
le roi Charlemagne
[Musique]
trois grands foudres tombèrent alors des
nues le premier combattre la puissante
Paris devant le palais du noble pépin là
où il tomba il fit une grande fausse de
la fosse on vit pousser depuis lors un
arbre long et droit fleuri et verdoyant
aussi longtemps que Charles vivrait
vivrait l'arbre
le récit n'est pas sans rappeler le rite
de l'arbre de mais que l'on plantait
jadis dans la cour du Palais à Paris où
place du village pour honorer la nature
féconde du printemps
c'est une coutume répandue dans tout
l'Occident
les deux autres foudre qui concernent
d'ohont et Garin opère de la même façon
avec l'arbre qui jaillit de la fosse
les trois garçons composent une trinité
chevaleresque placée ici au service de
la chrétienté
là où je naquie près du palais luisant
un autre foudre tomba devant la porte je
vis l'arbre tantôt quand on m'y
conduisit et là où est né garant advint
même chose ce fut grand révélation qui
fit parler et souvent l'on prophétisait
que nous trois furions durant nos vies
même bien et grands profitent à Dieu et
à sa loi
dans la Tradition Primordiale les trois
arbres n'en faisaient sans doute qu'un
seul l'arbre divin qui a jailli de
l'abîme creusé par la foudre
nos trois personnages seraient donc à
comprendre sur un plan vertical et
hiérarchique à l'image de l'arbre dont
la hauteur se partage entre branches
tronc et racines
le trio d’éclaire quoique non humain se
manifeste comme un personnage à part
entière
il se révèle comme le foudre de
l'Annonciation de la France comme on
parle de l'ange de l'Annonciation dans
le christianisme
combiné à une trinité le foudre est
censé donner vie par son action à toute
l'histoire sociale politique et
religieuse en devenir
cette cosmogonie précise remonte à la
Gaule païenne
[Musique]
la linguistique en fournit des indices
la langue gauloise a en effet conservé
trois mots pour dire monde albosit
à rixe qui veut dire roi les noms
antiques algory X
et dumurix signifie tout trois rois du
monde mais les trois mondes en question
ne sont pas situés à la même hauteur
le blanc du ciel est des dieux aériens
et gouvernés par albiorix blanc se dit
Albeau s'en Gaulois c'est la même racine
indo-européenne qui a donné en
germanique leur nom aux elfes
le noir du soumon des créatures
inférieures et gouvernées par dumonorix
noir sombre ou profondeur se dit du
gnose ou d'une douce
quant à l'entre-deux la vie sur terre
c'est le monde gouverné par biturix
albiorix biturix était peut-être des
noms de Dieu plus que de personnes
auxquelles ils formaient une trinité
mythique
au-delà de la Gaule la division du Cosmo
103 mondes est un héritage indo-européen
par exemple chez les Germains l'univers
serait né du dépeçage d'imir le géant
primordial par le trio originel formé
des dieux Odin Vili et V
chez les Grecs après la chute des Titans
le partage de l'univers fut réalisé par
les trois principaux dieux de l'Olympe
Zeus le céleste Poséidon le marin et
hadèse le souterrain
cette trinité mythologique existe aussi
dans la société indo-européenne il
s'agit des fameuses trois fonctions le
sacré la guerre et la production nommés
aussi clergé noblesse et tiers état
ainsi dans la matière de France
Charlemagne dohon et Garin forment une
trinité
héritée tout droit de l'ancienne culture
gauloise
même s'il y a eu adaptation locale du
mythe de européen primitif on peut dire
qu'au commencement de l'espace et du
temps est la Trinité
trois dieux dépassent le géant cosmique
chez les Germains
trois dieux se partagent l'univers chez
les Grecs trois lignages entre au
service de Dieu en France
toutefois dans notre hypnogenèse les
personnages dominants sont non pas les
trois humains et leur lignages encore
inopérants mais l'acteur premier à
savoir le triple foudre et ce qui sort
soudain de son acte créateur l'arbre
divin
si l'on suit la geste l'éclair et l'ange
de Dieu
envoie à Charles un ange qui ressemble à
un feu il rend elle clarté et si grand
de lueurs comme des éclairs que ceux qui
le voient sont effrayés aveuglés et si
ébloui qu'il ne voit rien sauf la clarté
de l'ange
notre ange au triple foudre remplit donc
le rôle d'un dieu cadre celui qui au
commencement des choses agit d'en haut
et mettent en place les personnages et
le décor de la pièce à suivre
Dieu délègue son autorité céleste allant
je foudroyant
tel est peut-être le sens naturaliste à
donner à certains reliefs
à Montmorillon par exemple une frise
esquintée présente structurellement des
similitudes avec le texte de la geste
l'ange à gauche se tient devant l'arbre
au centre et trois hommes à droite
on pourrait y reconnaître l'ange qui
jette la foudre l'arbre divin et les
trois lignages du royaume de France
[Musique]
comme souvent relief d’église stels
antiques et chansons de gestes s'éclaire
les uns les autres
on a vu que l'arbre divin jaillit
toujours d'un abîme l'arbre du Chaudron
devient destrupes pousse depuis la cuve
aux géants
l'arbre des églises pousse depuis la
gueule à l'envers
l'arbre de Charlemagne pousse depuis une
grande fausse
ce que le texte français nous apprend
ici c'est le rôle prophétique joué par
trois foudre en plein vacarme céleste
or sur le chaudron celtique que voit-on
juste au sommet de l'arbre c'est-à-dire
à droite
trois carnicks l'instrument avant à la
fois guerrier et religieux
qu'utilisaient les Celtes
[Musique]
il est frappant que sur le chaudron
celtique et dans la geste française on
retrouve de façon harmonieuse
l'arbre souverain comme personne âgée
centrale
un trio céleste associé au vacarme et au
vent trois foudres ou trois carnix et un
habit au pied de l'arbre cuve ou fausse
ce lien précis entre l'arbre et l'abîme
existent aussi dans un autre texte
dans Alice quand il est question d'un
certain arbre qui deux fois par an se
font pour recouvrer sa jeunesse et cet
arbre jouxte un abîme au-delà duquel
vivent entre autres des sagittaires
le roi païen Margot de bossidan tenait
le fief depuis des tours d'orquoise
jusqu'à l'abbaye où s'en vont les vents
c'est là dit-on que descend Lucifer nul
n'habite au-delà de ce royaume hormis
Sagittaire et lutins en deçà se dresse
le grand arbre qui Fendt deux fois l'un
pour rajeunir
le Sagittaire est un centaure qui
brandit un arc un Vézelay le centaure
archer monte ainsi la garde à l'entrée
même du sanctuaire
[Musique]
la cointance précise de l'arbre avec le
centaure résonne jusque sur des reliefs
d'église à Mozac 200 or encadrent
l'arbre à deux branches dont il présente
les pommes de pin au public
[Musique]
à
ennezatiques avec les deux cents qui
agrippent les deux branches de l'arbre
en général toutefois dans nos églises le
Sagittaire est associé non pas à l'arbre
mais au service des
le centaure pour chasse le cerf
[Musique]
j'ai longuement parlé de cette chasse au
cerf dans mon documentaire sur le dieu
gaulois Taranis
or il existe des similitudes évidentes
entre l'arbre et le cervidé la pousse du
bois branche ou un mur la chute de ce
qui a poussé chute des feuilles ou de la
ramure et le cycle perpétuel mort et
renaissance
en résumé les reliefs des églises
celtiques parlent souvent du même
personnage principal présenté sous
diverses apparences
l'arbre naturel qui se donne comme un
Mozac
l'arbre façonné à l'image de l'homme
comme un Vinci l'homme façonné à l'image
de l'arbre avec une chevelure de
feuillage comme un Châteaumeillant
enfin le servide dont les bois
s'apparentent évidemment à l'arbre comme
à Aulnay de Saintonge
toutes ces figures si différentes au
premier abord reposent en fait sur un
dénominateur commun le même Dieu vivant
y est représenté Dieu qui meurt et
ressuscite d'où l'allégorie permanente
avec l'arbre
sur le chaudron de gain des strupes la
plaque de la cuve au géant présente
comme on a vu l'arbre souverain en
position horizontale le tronc est
entouré d'un épée à l'eau de stries qui
indique à l'évidence l'énergie
vitalisante de l'arbre douce et fleurs
déployées sur tout le long
or cette énergie vitalisante semble
jouer un rôle dans les lances en bois de
certains guerriers
en bas au centre ce succèdent 6 piétons
chacun tient sa lance verticale un bout
de lance touche le sol tandis que
l'autre bout effleure l'arbre et baigne
de fait dans son halo irradiant on note
qu'en bas à droite le dernier soldat à
pied porte encore sa lance sur l'épaule
comme s'il venait d'arriver
en haut des quatre cavaliers deux
seulement portent des lances le premier
à droite et le troisième
les seules guerriers à avoir la pointe
de lance au milieu des fleurs sont les
six piétons au centre c'est à dire ceux
qui font la queue devant le géant pour
semble-t-il se réincarner et remonter à
cheval
nos six piétons ont si l'on peut dire
leur lance fleurie et ils sont les élus
en marge vers le dieu bienfaiteur
en écho assez longs fleuries des reliefs
d'église présentent souvent des hommes
qui tiennent en main un végétale branche
lance ouceptre parfois coiffé d'une
fleur ou d'un fruit
à Mauzac dans un décor de vigne un
guerrier repose sa lance dans le creux
de son coude et mange de copieuse
grappes de raisin
sur une frise à
Saint-Paul-Trois-Châteaux à droite deux
hommes à grippe des perches fleuries
à Saint restitue une frise murale figure
Dieu sous la forme d'un géant nain B et
vêtue d'une Europe de cérémonie de part
et d'autre des personnes en procession
s'approchent de lui ceux de droite
tiennent des sortes de lances fleuries
s'élance fleurit son parfois agrippés
par des non-humains ainsi à plein pied
un humanoïde Cimiez que tient une tige
longiligne comme un arbuste avec une
fleur à la cime
sur le chaudron de gain des scrup on
trouve la composante le cheval et la
lance fleurie tenue en main
oragravi une scène résume la composante
un cheval bicore en poigne avec sa main
humaine le tronc d'un arbuste au branche
haute toute feuille
le sens de cette scène est peut-être un
rapproché de girolles où c'est l'agneau
pascal qui tient une perche coiffée
d'une croix
à Graville comme à girolles les
similitudes structurelles sont évidentes
un quadrupède cheval ou agneau tient
dans sa main ou sa patte avant une tige
en bois arbuste ou perche surmontés d'un
signe de force feuillage ou croix
or sur le chaudron sacré la tige en bois
la lance plonge sa pointe dans le halo
d'énergie de l'arbre divin
dans tous les cas c'est la même
composante de ce que l'on serait tenté
d'appeler le sceptre d'immortalité
la cime de la tige lance perche ou
arbuste et coiffer du signe
d'immortalité à l'eau d'énergie croit
feuillage
on comprend dès lors que cette lance
fleur de Lisée se retrouve dans la main
d'un ange à Fontevraud l'ange qui se
présente devant le roi tient une lance
coiffée d'un lys
à Saint-Germain-des-Prés l'ange tient un
sceptre fleur de Lisée
à bles le roi tient le bâton fleur de
lysée
à Saint-Martin de Boscherville une reine
guide le roi à cheval elle brandit
devant lui deux lices de ses mains
au fond la lance de l'ange avec son
lisse à la cime n'est que la version
réduite de l'arbre divin dont le cœur
fleurit thalassim comme à plein pied
et à Beaugency
dans les chansons de gestes la tradition
celtique de la lance fleurie a été très
bien conservée et elle fait la jonction
entre deux éléments d'une part la lance
fleurie du guerrier qui va mourir
d'autre part la mort du cheval du roi
c'est-à-dire précisément les deux thèmes
que l'on rencontre sur le chaudron de
gain destrues avec l'homme à la lance
fleurie en bas et l'homme à cheval en
haut
la Chronique de Turpin est un récit
mythologique du 12e siècle qui raconte
la vie de Charlemagne l'empereur des
Francs
la première près de la rivière de la C&A
en Espagne la seconde en France près de
la Charente devant la cité de Saintes
dans les deux cas le cheval de
Charlemagne meurt mais les Francs
finissent quand même victorieux
le point qui nous intéresse ici c'est
l'événement qui précède la bataille
l'armée franc a dressé ses tantes dans
une prairie les soldats y plantent leur
lance dans la terre et s'en vont dormir
pendant la nuit se produit un miracle
des lances prennent racine si bien qu'au
point du jour la prairie ressemble à une
forêt
or toutes ces lances vivantes
appartiennent à ceux qui vont mourir sur
le champ d'honneur et rejoindre le ciel
une fois l'accord conclu pendant la nuit
qui précédait la bataille une partie des
chrétiens désireux de lutter Fischer
leur lance droites devant leur campement
dans la prairie le long du fleuve de la
CIA et quand va le matin ceux qui
devaient recevoir le martyr pour notre
Seigneur trouvèrent leur lance toute
chargée d'écorce et de feuilles
la saga de Charlemagne confirme la
tradition culturelle s'élance fleurit
transforme toute la prairie en épaisse
forêt
des rameaux et des feuilles se mirent à
pousser sur les lances et ce qui était
auparavant un champ de vingt une forêt
les guerriers francs tranchent de leur
épée l'arbuste pour en refaire une lance
mais les racines étant profondes le bois
a repoussé et l'on peut encore y voir la
forêt en question
il les tranchèrent tout près de la Terre
mais des racines restantes 20 grandes
perches et crues grands bois qui est
encore visible en celui une grande
partie de ses lances était de Fresnes
lors de la mêlée trouve la mort
notamment mi-long le père de Roland et
le cheval de Charlemagne
le duc-milon perd de Roland y a reçu la
mort ainsi que ceux dont on avait trouvé
les hampes feuillus et le cheval de
Charles fut aussi sous lui
notons que les chrétiens remportèrent la
bataille le lendemain grâce au concours
de 4 Marquises
4 héros dont on ne sait rien mais qui
par leur nombre semble les col
légendaire des célèbres 4 fils et
lors de la seconde bataille l'enjeu et
la ville de Saintes sur la Charente
et la même scène se répète
la nuit avant la bataille il advint que
l'une et l'autre partie des chrétiens
fichèrent leur lance devant leur camp
dans le pré situé entre le château de
Taillebourg et la cité de Saintes qui
est sur l'eau de la Charente au matin ce
qui devait recevoir le martyr pour la
foi de notre Seigneur tout vers leur
lance chargé de feuilles de fleurs à la
vue de ce miracle il furent stupéfaits
il tranchèrent leur lance près de la
terre puis il sera semblèrent les
premiers à la bataille il tuait un moule
sarrasin mais à la fin il furent tous
aussi et emporté au saint cieux et
couronnés de couronnes éternelles
et le cheval de l'empereur connaît le
même sort funeste
la même fut de nouveau oxy le cheval de
Charlemagne
les Francs remportent la bataille et la
cité de Saintes
le nom de Saintes n'est évidemment pas
fortuit
par cette victoire terrestre les
chrétiens morts sur le champ d'honneur
accèdent au pays des saints au paradis
[Musique]
le récit de la chronique médiévale
repose à l'évidence sur le légendaire
celtique de l'Antiquité
[Musique]
dans la matière de France ou de Gaulle
en effet les lances qui fleurissent
appartiennent au guerriers déjà mort ou
qui vont mourir
un cheval particulier meurt aussi celui
du roi
les quatre marques qui vainqueurs
rappellent les quatre cavaliers du
chaudron où les 4 filsmons de légendaire
français enfin la mort est toujours
suivie d'une renaissance soit par
réincarnation soit par l'accès au
paradis
[Musique]
ainsi la même tradition celtique est à
l'œuvre
sur le chaudron de guerre des trucs les
lances des guerriers des fins ont la
pointe au milieu des fleurs de l'arbre
divin sonore d'église lescepres fleur de
lisées sont tenus par des anges ou des
personnages dont l'âme est pure
enfin dans nos textes médiévaux
fleurissent les lances des guerriers qui
vont gagner le paradis
jadis honoré par les druides l'arbre
divin a traversé les âges
présentés d'abord comme un chêne porteur
de Guy
ou un homme arbre à tête
cet arbre celtique est conservé dans nos
églises anciennes
à des degrés divers fusion de l'homme et
de l'arbre
[Musique]
le passage au christianisme biblique se
fait en douceur
la croix hérite de l'arbre à travers les
scènes de crucifixion
et de déposition
on retrouve chez les peuples germaniques
un transfert théologique de même nature
avec l'image du Dieu souverain Odin qui
se pend lui-même au frêne ickdrasil
une forme de Trinité existait déjà en
Gaule avec le dieu à trois têtes carnuno
que ces bois sur le crâne apparente à
l'arbre
Trinité végétale que l'on reconnaît dans
le lys au bas de la Sainte Face de Dieu
au passage de la Gaule à la France la
monarchie hérite du licératique le
fameux fleur de lys médiéval emblème du
royaume de France en tire à l'évidence
son origine
les armoiries de France sont comme
blason d'azur au semis de lys d'or ou
d'azur aux trois lys d'or
lors des divers redécoupages
administratifs de la France m'intéresse
ont conservé le fleur de lys dans leurs
armoiries
[Musique]
fidèle à ses origines l'Amérique
française à hissé le lys sur son drapeau
le liste de France descend de l'arbre
divin de nos églises celtiques
et de l'arbre divin de l'ancienne
Gaumont